voting wraps up today in moscow's
so-called referendums in
russian-controlled parts of Ukraine
kremlin-backed leaders in the region say
provisional results can be expected as
soon as this evening but Kiev and its
allies say the results are a foregone
conclusion Moscow is expected to
formally Annex the four regions
following the vote raising fears among
residents about their future
vote Into The Ballot Box should mean
having a say in one's future
but outside of Russia and Ukraine's
separatist regions not many believe the
kremlin's listening over the last few
days State television has been showing
polling stations packed with
enthusiastic yes voters
this referendum is the purpose of the
last 10 years of my life
and upbeat election workers being
welcomed in their homes by people eager
to join the motherland
one of them seemed to already know the
result
great mood the turnout is very high so
we are happy with the result
everything's fine
foreign footage circulating on social
media paints a very different picture of
the so-called referendum
empty streets and election workers
struggling to find people to vote
another video from Maria Paul shared by
the Ukrainian city government in Exile
shows armed soldiers following election
workers into residential buildings
a warning by Ukrainian authorities that
people will face criminal punishment if
they vote prompted some to leave
and others to hide behind closed doors
[Music]
no matter how many ballots I cast in the
end the Ukrainian leadership and its
Western allies say the referendum is a
sham
a pretext for the Kremlin to Annex the
full regions in which it is held
luhansk Donetsk separagia and Harrison
many ordinary ukrainians think the same
they are worse than fascists it's simply
unbearable
with a wall escalating continuously over
the last few months many ukrainians left
their homes long before Moscow staged
its so-called referendum on their future
for those who stayed Remains The Fear
they'll soon have to live as citizens of
Russia
and perhaps even become Fighters for its
Army
DW correspondent batius Berlinger joins
us for the latest from Ukraine's Capital
Kiev Matthias what have you been hearing
about the conditions under which people
in occupied areas must vote
well this annexation Paul is many call
it it violates probably all Norms of a
democratic referendum or election there
first of all the conditions under War
where many people have left the area and
those who stay they do not represent
necessarily the majority of the
population there has been no preparation
in terms of informing the population
that's also a requirement that the
voters must be well informed and that
they must know all their options this
has not been underway and then the
process itself we've seen these
transparent ballot boxes we've seen
people ticking their box in front of the
people sitting behind these ballot boxes
so there are no voting Goods there's no
there's no say or there's no there are
no conditions that would guarantee
um some kind of privacy to the voters so
um all these Norms we've also seen these
people to entering buildings with
soldiers in their town and knocking on
doors asking people to cast their box so
there's their vote so all of these
conditions they're vile like all Norms
of a democratic
referendum and uh we cannot
possibly take these the results of this
referendum any seriously so it doesn't
sound free or fair and it's happened at
lightning speed and it sounds like the
results are going to come out quite
quickly too
that's what we're hearing
um there's also probably no need to take
a long time to count these votes as most
of them seem to be predetermined what we
might be seeing is that the Kremlin
might move pretty quickly in annexing
these regions that's the purpose of this
exercise that the Kremlin will have some
kind of a reason to proceed with
annexation and to change the narrative
about this war because after this of
course in the kremlin's view Russia will
be Ukraine will be fighting Uh Russian
territory what about the ukrainians
though who've decided to stay don't want
to live under Russian control
but may want to get out quite soon
it's been difficult to leave these
territories it's been possible but
difficult people have been spending days
at the checkpoints if they want to cross
over to Ukrainian control territory and
it's even been more difficult for men to
leave the territory because the
checkpoints would often not let men pass
now with the general mobilization uh in
in Russia having started of course the
fear for these people who live in these
territories for the men who live in
these territories is that they might be
drafted into the Russian army
thank you very much for your analysis